Managing focus when you navigate
on the page is really important.
But sometimes you'll need to manage
focus at the component level as well,
especially if you're building
a complex custom widget.
To show you what I mean, take a look
at this native select tag and
notice how I can focus it.
And once there, I can use the arrow
keys to expose additional functionality,
like selecting different options.
If you were building a custom
select element yourself or
something similar like a drop-down,
you would need to expose these same
kinds of behaviors so that your users
who rely primarily on the keyboard
could still interact with your control.
Now knowing which keyboard behaviors
to implement can be a bit of a guessing
game but, thankfully there's a really
helpful guide which you can refer to.
The ARIA design pattern stock,
lists various kinds of components
as well as the sorts of keyboard
interactions that they support.
Now, Alice is going to cover ARIA in
more detail in the following sections,
but for now, let's use this guide
to help us add keyboard support
to a new component which
we're going to build.